siempre que me mencionan el concepto la
palabra de justicia a mí se me viene a
la mente la imagen de themis
según la mitología griega themis era la
diosa de la justicia ítem y siempre
estaba representado está representada
con una balanza en su mano izquierda una
balanza que representa el orden el
equilibrio una espada en su mano derecha
que no es la espada de themis es la
espada del némesis la diosa griega de la
venganza que representa el castigo al
desobediente la necesidad de sancionar a
quien interrumpe quien afecta ese orden
y ese equilibrio
themis además y esto es una cosa que a
mí particularmente me llama siempre la
atención es que tiene una venda en los
ojos
themis siempre tiene vendados los ojos y
eso que significa que la justicia tiene
que ser ciega que la justicia no puede
ver ni de raza ni de género ni de
orientación sexual de religión de
estatus social de ideología la justicia
tiene que ser completamente ecuánime
objetiva e imparcial
me acuerdo en mis primeras clases de
derecho yo soy abogada que un profesor
en introducción al derecho creo que las
primeras primeras clases siempre decía
el eslogan de derecho de la justicia es
dime los hechos que yo te diré el
derecho y siempre me acordaba de themis
con su venda los ojos dime los hechos y
yo te diré el derecho el resto no
importa
bueno yo no sé a ustedes pero yo soy
adicta a las redes sociales
me encanta ver instagram me encanta ver
facebook
me encanta ver whatsapp pues soy
completamente adicta y me encanta ver
twitter y también me gusta mucho ver las
noticias leer periódicos ver las
noticias por internet ver las noticias
en la televisión y todos los días me
encuentro con casos que me sorprenden me
acuerdo un caso hace aproximadamente dos
años de un señor
a quien condenaron a cinco meses y siete
días de cárcel en la picota en bogotá
por haberse robado dos cajas de
chocolatinas
y bueno no sé si ustedes se acuerdan o
pues un caso que a mí me indignó y que
me sorprendió hace muy poco es de una
persona un señor también a quien le
pusieron una multa de 800 mil pesos más
de 250 dólares por comprar una empanada
en la calle
y bueno eso también me acuerdo de un
caso que es incluso más reciente y es el
caso de una palenquera la palenquera es
una mujer del caribe colombiano
que se viste con una pollera grande una
pollera que normalmente lleva los
colores de la bandera de colombia una
camisa una camisa y que tiene un tinajo
lleno de frutas y de dulces en su cabeza
pues bien la palenquera lo que hace es
vender esas frutas esas esos dulces las
negocia en las calles de cartagena es
una figura cultural de cartagena hace
tres semanas una palenquera también fue
multada no sé en verdad por cuánta plata
pero por invadir el espacio público
todos los días a toda hora en todo
momento nos estamos encontrando con
casos que a mí me indignan y yo sé que
muchos de ustedes también que nos
sorprenden y nos hacen preguntarnos todo
el tiempo es justa esta justicia
bueno les cuento que hay un show en
particular que a mí me gusta mucho que
es el show del juez frank caprio en eeuu
el juez frank caprio
normalmente recibe casos de infracciones
de tránsito en road atlanta en eeuu y
pues hace unos meses llegó un caso muy
particular se trataba de un señor entre
40 40 45 años quien había cometido una
infracción de tránsito
pues como transcurre la audiencia ante
este juez lo primero que pasa es que
proyectan el vídeo de la infracción en
el televisor ahí de la sala de
audiencias y que se ve un señor
conduciendo un carro que se pasa un
semáforo en rojo
ni siquiera en amarillo ni siquieran
anaranjado como decimos coloquialmente
aquí en colombia sino completamente en
rojo en rojo pasión pues bueno el hecho
de la infracción estaba ahí
como sigue la audiencia el juez caprio
le pregunta a esta persona a este señor
cuénteme cómo se llama usted qué hace y
pues que estaba pasando en ese momento
porque se pasó el semáforo el señor le
responde señor juez qué pena yo no me
acuerdo de haber cometido esa infracción
de haberme pasado este semáforo pero
pues le cuento que yo soy un veterano de
la guerra de irak
yo serví en el ejército de eeuu entre
2003 y 2004 y cuando estaba en la guerra
sufrió varios ataques en especial un
bombardeo por causa del cual tuve una
lesión en la columna vertebral y después
de haber vuelto otra vez a eeuu después
de la guerra me diagnosticaron un cáncer
que después dijeron que era consecuencia
de la radiación de los bombardeos
bueno también sufrí por mucho tiempo de
estrés postraumático no he podido
conseguir trabajo y hoy en día sufro de
trastorno de ansiedad tengo una
enfermedad que se llama trastorno de
ansiedad y de depresión porque realmente
no he logrado conseguir trabajo
ahora esa imagen de ese televisor me
acuerda de un barrio y es un barrio que
yo frecuento una vez al mes una vez cada
tres semanas y es porque voy todas las
pues todos los meses cada tres semanas a
donde el médico psiquiatra del hospital
de veteranos para que me trate este
trastorno de ansiedad
ante esta situación el juez caprio
separa y pronuncia el siguiente
veredicto yo no puedo ser un juez
irresponsable un juez indolente usted
sufre de una condición que fue causa de
un servicio que le prestó a esta nación
a esta sociedad nosotros hoy todos
estamos sentados acá por su servicio a
la democracia me sentiría indolente y
responsable en ponerle una multa de 50 a
100 dólares y por esa razón lo mínimo el
mínimo gesto de agradecimiento de
nosotros como nación es revocarle esa
sanción
bueno volviendo un poco a la historia de
tenis les cuento que tenis se aburrió de
estar en la tierra de mí se aburrió de
la cantidad de injusticias de injusticia
que reinaba en la tierra de todos los
días que se le presentaban casos que le
parecían demasiado injustos y se
horrorizó entonces cogió sus maletas y
se largó otra vez para el olimpo se fue
de la tierra qué tan ridículo es que la
diosa griega de la justicia en verdad se
aburre de la tierra porque hay demasiada
injusticia
eso a mí me lleva a pensar no sería que
hay una forma más justa de hacer
justicia será que la justicia implacable
es la solución no será que habrá una
forma de hacer una justicia terrenal o
de impartir justicia acá en la tierra de
hacer la justicia más humana
ese juez que condenó a una persona a
cinco meses de cárcel cinco meses y
siete días hábiles de cárcel por robarse
dos paquetes de chocolatinas en un
supermercado no supo en su momento y no
indagó en su momento que la persona
sufría de una adicción al chocolate
también tenía un trastorno de ansiedad y
comía chocolate de manera compulsiva
había cometido la misma infracción de
robarse un par de cajas de chocolates
por muchas veces el juez lo que vio es
que se trataba de un delincuente
reincidente y en esa medida le puso esa
pena
ahora no estoy justificando el robo en
ningún sentido
vayan a confundir
que no vio la autoridad que puso la
multa en el caso de las palenqueras que
la calle es inherente a las palenqueras
la calle es intrínseca a la
manifestación cultural que son estas
mujeres en las calles de cartagena sin
calla no hay palenquera porque
precisamente su función y su
manifestación es llenar de colorido y de
alegría a los transeúntes ya los
extranjeros y a los colombianos que
paseamos por las calles de cartagena no
solamente con el colorido de sus trajes
sino también el colorido de las frutas y
de los dulces que venden
entonces si yo sí creo que hay formas de
hacer más justa la justicia y creo que
hay formas de impartir justicia aquí en
la tierra de hacer la justicia más
humana y para mí esa justicia más humana
es una justicia que ve el contexto que
entiende el problema en su integridad
es una justicia que entiende además las
implicaciones de las sanciones cuando
piensa en una decisión en una solución
piensa cuáles son las implicaciones que
va más allá de simplemente poner una
multa o poner una sanción
y es una justicia que sanciona desde la
empatía es una justicia que se pone en
los zapatos del otro en los tenis del
otro por qué no decirlo así
es una de mis ante mis
y por qué no también con un tinajo de
frutas y de dulces en la cabeza
bueno
con esta imagen de tenis en tenis de
cómo hacer la justicia más terrenal de
cómo de pronto en una sociedad donde
reina la injusticia la justicia
implacable de pronto no es la solución
yo siempre me preguntado o pues siempre
me han dicho profesores tutores que aún
no no debe juzgar yo creo que una cosa
es juzgar y otra cosa es tener
prejuicios
todos en todo momento estamos juzgando
la justicia debe ser entendida como una
virtud como un valor
todos nos estamos formando opiniones de
nuestro entorno de las situaciones
estamos criticando y criticar es bueno
lo importante es desde donde lo hacemos
y es por eso que yo les propongo que lo
hagamos desde los zapatos de los demás
desde los tenis de los demás desde la
empatía
hay una cosa que no les conté de la
historia de themis en un principio y es
que te mis aparte de ser la diosa griega
de la justicia también era la diosa del
buen consejo
te mismo era colérico themis no era
soberbia es más tenis fue la única en
ofrecerle una copa de vino a era cuando
volvió afligida y asustada al olimpo
después de recibir múltiples amenazas
y maltratos por parte de zeus
themis era compasiva de mí sentía que
mis podía tener una venda en los ojos
pero themis tenía corazón
y eso me lleva a acordarme oa resumir
cuál es el entendimiento real que yo
tengo de la justicia
y también voy a acordarme de una frase
que pronuncia a mi abuelito muchas veces
muchas veces
y es que el corazón tiene razones que la
propia razón no entiende
[Aplausos]